-Guys, it is summer,
and I'm always looking for
a good book to read, okay?
A good beach read, okay?
Now, in the past,
we've done contests on the show.
We'd pick a few books and then
vote on which one to read.
But this year,
we're not doing that.
-What?
-We're doing things
a little different.
I made a decision this year.
-What?
-I just picked a book.
I chose --
I'm doing a book club.
This is --
We're all doing the book club.
Yeah. Yeah. Everyone.
Roots, everybody.
-You got it?
-Mandatory book club.
-Oh!
-Yeah.
That's the way we do it here.
This year, it's mandatory.
-We have to read it?
-You have to read it.
-Aw!
-Yeah.
-Can somebody read it to me?
-No, this one's fantastic.
I picked it out.
It's a good one.
I love it.
It involves --
It's a love story.
-Love it.
-You love love?
-Yeah.
-About two kids that --
They love each other.
It's in the '90s.
They create
a video game together.
-Oh!
-And then it just gets --
Yeah, exactly, yeah.
It is called "Tomorrow,
and Tomorrow, and Tomorrow"
by Gabrielle Zevin, everybody.
This is the book.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is it.
It's officially
the very first book
in our brand-new
Fallon Book Club.
-Ooh.
-Look at that.
We have a sticker.
Look at the sticker.
Can we zoom in?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, yeah!
-Oh, man! FBC!
-That's as much as we
could zoom in?
-FBC!
-It feels like the camera zoomed
in a little bit, then stopped.
-We can't afford that.
-Yeah! Look at that.
That's tight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But look --
Just holding it looks cool.
-Oh, nice!
-What's up man?
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Rhythmic clapping ]
Okay. I can't wait. This is --
-Beach!
-It's got everything you want
in this thing.
This is the summer read,
the Fallon Book Club.
This is the jam right here.
It says here, "A dazzling
and intricately imagined novel
that imagines the nature of
identity, failure,
the redemptive possibilities
in play, and, above all,
our need to connect,
to be loved, and to love.
Yes, it is a love story,
but it is not one
you have read before."
-Ooh!
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-So, here's how this works.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-That was good, right?
-Yeah.
-I'm going to be reading this
over the next few weeks,
and if you want to
read along with me,
pick up a copy
wherever books are sold
or go to your local library.
I'll be posting
my updates on my socials
about where I'm at in the book,
what I think of it.
And then we're going to have
the author, Gabrielle Zevin,
on the show
to talk about the book.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a book club.
-Hey!
-Some people
don't know about book clubs.
-No, never.
-I ain't gonna join
no book club.
-What?
-I don't want to join
no book club.
-Well, here, try this book.
-What the heck?
-It's called "Tomorrow,
and Tomorrow, and Tomorrow."
-I like this book.
I'm going to be in
more book clubs.
-I'm going to be in
way more...
[ Inhales deeply ]
...book clubs.
Is it part of the FBC?
-Oh, you're in the FBC!
Fallon Book Club.
-2022.
[ Imitates air horn blowing ]
[ Air horn blows ]
Thank you, yeah.
-Vuvuzela!
What does that mean?
[ Laughter ]
But, anyways, to start,
to kick things off,
tonight,
everyone in our studio audience
will be going home
with their very own copy of
"Tomorrow, and Tomorrow,
and Tomorrow."
That's what I'm saying.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It's a Fallon Book Club!
[ Imitates air horn blowing ]
[ Air horn blows ]
Happy reading, everybody!
♪♪
-♪ Read it ♪
♪ I'm gonna talk about it ♪
♪ I'm gonna read it ♪
♪ I'm gonna shout about it ♪
♪ Gonna sing about it ♪
♪ I'm gonna rap about it ♪
♪ Gonna scratch about it ♪
♪ Gonna worm about it ♪
♪ Gonna spin about it ♪
♪ Go up about it ♪
♪ Go down about it ♪
♪♪
[ Air horn blows ]
-I'm starting to pick it up.
Yeah. And the horns came in.